good evening everyone and thanks to
pydera berlin for having me
today i'll be talking about defects or
why i have trust issues
uh so let's begin
so uh one thing i've heard and sure all
of you have heard as well
is that a picture is worth a thousand
words but uh what if that picture is
actually fake
so then what does it say turns out it
actually says more
and based on whom and where you ask it
could contain a lot of misinformation
so let's look at this picture uh and
this picture is
looks very much like a human but it's
completely fake
and it's been generated by an ai program
so if you look at this website called
this person does not exist.com
so like every time you go there it will
generate a fake image
and uh turns out that there are a ton of
these sites
and based on what you like i'm sure
there's something for everyone starting
from this this meme does not exist
the startup does not exist and also for
cat fans this cat does not exist
so you know that's where my trust issues
you know time to
you know begin so let's look at this
defect which has been circulated by uh
you know it's coming
very popular this month and it's a
defect of tom cruise
it's a little uh embarrassing you know
it reminds me i was once in
russia i ran into uh gorbachev
he said yummy standard movie star
are you nervous tick-tock
you guys cool if i play some sports
as you can see like this is the
statement
uh in 2021 uh this is what you can do
but it's not all fun uh because uh
defects cause a lot of problems
and uh there was this incident where a
journalist was
uh investigating or rather exposing a
sex child uh
sorry child sex abuse case and uh
to silence her they started with the
misinformation campaign
about some fake tweets and uh when she
didn't stop so they launched a
fake porn of her and that
kind of had a very you know big
big effect on her and starting with
discrediting her as a journalist
and it ended quite badly
and this is not that uncommon so
uh you can see a lot of these defects
being used
to essentially alter public opinion
starting with a defect of belgian
premier talking about that climate
crisis is imminent
and linking that to covet and we also
have other cases where in india
there was a bjp leader there was a
political party
uh trying to reach out to their voters
in their local language and the
audio was generated was used by
uh was generated by an ai and
uh right now the uh like before
the entry to use the rather the entry
barrier to use uh the fake technology
was
kind of like only like the experts could
use it let's say
but that has been going down so we have
been seeing the rise of uh defects
as a technical barrier to creating them
goes down
so right now the true estimation is
around 100 million plus defects
in 2021 and a lot of them have to do
with the easy to use apps
so there is this very popular app called
uh reface
uh you might have heard of it it
actually was trending
at one point like it was trending at
number one in entertainment it also beat
uh tick tock
so it allows you to uh to easily create
defect videos
and uh this was a news article which i
read yesterday
it was a mother uh using defeat to
actually frame her daughter's uh rivals
that
they were doing uh like essentially
create a fake video of their rivals so
it's as you can see it's no longer you
know uh just being used for to
defame uh celebrities or used to for
political agendas it could the next
victim could be you or me
so this is has like probably like right
now is like the tipping point
so the cost of this information annually
as estimated in 2019
it was around 78 billion and
the most alarming thing is that fall
stories actually reach six times faster
compared to true stories so the
infiltration if you launch a defect is
much
faster so now let's look at a few types
of defect
so the first one is face swapping so
what happens is that you have a source
phase
this is original and the target phase
and
uh the bi model kind of learns uh what
are the feature features of the source
and the target are
and essentially swaps these and creates
a super imposition to
manipulate a face swap defect
and then you have the second type which
is facial reenactment
so what happens is that you have the
source video
and and the target so uh
you can like for example make uh facial
movements or speak anything you want and
that will kind of be mimicked on
the target phase so you could make any
person say anything that you want
and this is kind of a pretty dangerous
right
uh you can also have full body defects
where you essentially move the target's
entire body to whatever pose you like
and then the fourth category of course
which is audio defect
uh where you can generate uh an audio
which has been uh
uh like uh may make a person's voice
so there was this case where a company
ceo
was uh so a defect of the company ceo
was used
to mimic a wire transfer of around 243
000 and this has been
a rising problem
so let's look at this video i'm not
going to say to you if this is uh
fake or real uh let's see how you can
probably
look at this when mexico sends its
people they're not sending their best
they're not sending you they're not
sending you
they're sending people that have lots of
problems
and they're bringing those problems with
us
they're bringing drugs they're bringing
crime
they're rapists so uh
maybe you know if you've seen this uh if
it's uh
fake or not or real so and that's you
you know where the
trust issue really starts to begin where
you even start to doubt
what's a real video and you think
probably that's a fake
so it's kind of
and uh the trust issues start to
increase and uh probably like
to the moon so there was uh this uh
um report published by a republican hub
republican candidate and uh he claimed
that
uh the george floyd's death incident was
completely fake
and digitally manipulated using defect
now that's of course uh false but
uh it's that just because uh you
there just because defect exists it kind
of puts
into jeopardy the entire uh like a real
video might be called as you know it's
defect it doesn't exist
you probably just created it
so uh some of the trust issues are like
uh you know
defects can be used to cause fraud
espionage inside mental or physical harm
like we saw
in case of the uh journalist and
we have been seeing uh increase in these
kind of crimes
particularly against women where
someone's uh sales are
rather black males that a person's uh d
fake
porn might be used uh and
uh there are of course other uh aspects
to it like
influencing judicial proceedings to the
point of
actually threatening national integrity
and security
so what does what does the future hold
uh
so now right now we have ai generated uh
text so like there's a very popular
model called gpt3
which can be used to generate any kind
of text that you want
and now you have defects to generate any
kind of video
or gans to generating kind of image so
you essentially have all the tools to
generate whatever event you want and you
can do that at scale
and thus you can manipulate opinion and
essentially spread this information
so how does dfake work so
uh one of the most popular approaches
used in defect is
by using something called as auto
encoders so in an auto encoder
architecture there is typically three
blocks
so one is the encoder uh one is the
bottleneck
and you have the decoder so the
encoder's job is essentially to
encode information uh like an image
which is a high
uh it's a high dimensional
representation into a low representation
or rather encoded which is stored in the
bottleneck
and the decoder decodes that information
again to
that previous image so usually the
decoder just reconstructs the
tries to reconstruct that input now with
the
auto encoders you can do multiple things
and one of them is
you can create uh fake images or
anything you want
so how you can use and go auto encoders
to
uh you know essentially create defects
is that you have this encoder block
which is uh kind of uh shared so uh
we'll actually need two uh auto encoders
for uh creating defects
so uh so the first part is the top part
which you see is the
source image and the bottom is the
target
so the source image is uh you could be
yourself and the
target is that whatever you want to
impose like a
target person let's say you want to swap
donald trump's image
on alec baldwin so alec baldwin here is
the target and donald trump here is the
source
so in this architecture the encoder is
actually is the same for both the
source and the target and we have two
separate decoders so uh for the source
um input we going to encode it and again
decode it exactly
to donald trump's uh image and for the
um target we are going to do the same
and this is what happens in the training
part
and when you want to actually generate
uh the
the let's say a defect what you're going
to do is
let's say use the encoder part for uh
for donald trump's image and use the
decoder part for
alec baldwin's so what you have uh here
is that
by using a diff like the source from the
encoder and the decoder part for the
targets you will essentially
kind of swap uh the faces now
uh this is not exactly like
state-of-the-art stuff because uh
there's a lot of artifacts usually
present
and with the previous approach uh you
wouldn't need like pairs of
uh videos so it would require a lot of
training
and you can't exactly use that uh for
like in inference or like testing
whenever you want
so you will need a lot of uh data to
create someone's defect
but technology has been improving since
then so you have this
something an architecture called as f
scan which is kind of subject agnostic
and what that means is that you do not
need uh you know a pairwise training
so uh so if you do not have a source
uh on a target video uh um
like a training data of it so uh you can
still use this because
uh when you actually want to use this uh
sort of architecture
to create your own defect you do not
need to gather a lot of data and need
pairs of source image and target video
so how does this work is by using
something called as the generative
adversarial network
then the way it works is that you have
two blocks essentially one is the
generator and another is the
discriminator
the generators essentially creates
no fake images and the discriminator's
job is to
try to differentiate between the real
images and
fake images and the discriminator does
this really well at first
but ultimately the generator actually
manages to fool the discriminator
into thinking that the fake image is a
real image
and by generating these kind of uh
you know this sort of a training
procedure
we are actually able to create fake
images which are very
uh lifelike uh such kind of sort of the
stuff which you saw in the beginning
uh where we where i showed you an image
of a fake person
so how does this work in fsgan is that
for example if you have the source and
you have the target
uh what you calculate first is kind of
like
landmarks so these so these would be
guiding phase landmarks so a landmark is
essentially
what you see on the left over here and
uh so
it contains uh you know points to uh
your face uh and it picks out like uh
very specific uh and important features
of your face which
can be used to represent so
in this first part you have these guys
sort of guiding face landmarks
and uh this will be used uh to kind of
uh first uh be passed to a generator to
first of all
align this uh source phase into sort of
the way the target space
is uh uh looking at so so the first
thing which happens over here is
the post correction and uh over here
uh the target space will be
passed uh another generator which kind
of separates
uh all these uh like separates
the various uh parts of the face so you
have the face separated out and
the other parts of the image will be
again separated out like the hair
or a earring or something like that
and then essentially uh we'll be
kind of uh using the landmarks which we
got
to essentially train our generator
to essentially make uh
generate images uh or essentially gets
us
sort of like how the movement of the
face is working
so we have multiple images so if it's a
video
we can extract multiple frames and we'll
get
a lot of these landmarks so that's why
you have multiple landmarks
and once and and if you interpolate
between them
you can get an idea of how to move the
source or rather than uh to move the
object object so uh kind of the source's
face in a way the target's face is
moving
and once you have that you can uh do
something called as in painting so
typically
uh once we have this image uh you can
see like a lot of parts on this image
are kind of
uh not completed and this is very
typical because you always have partial
occlusions
and that can be filled up by an in
painting uh
network which essentially
fills up this image by picking up detail
from
the target face so whatever uh you know
missing features are from the source
you can probably pick it up on the
target's face and create something and
complete this image
and the last part is the blending part
where the source
uh space is so you know really blended
well
to the target phase to the point of
looking like you know very real life
like
and uh this is uh open source so you can
try this out
uh it's present in the github repository
of the
paper which is called fsgan and they
also have a collab notebook so you can
try it out really fast so
let's look at how you can actually spot
a fake image
and this will be a manual procedure so
over here we can see
uh image and this was released by north
korea's
central news agency and they were trying
to
uh show a military exercise where north
korea's
hovercraft sorry hovercrafts uh were
uh were landing on their east coast
so and over here you can see like they
have multiple hovercrafts here
and it's actually a fake image
so over here if you see uh
this uh left uh block
and if you compare it with the right
block you'll see that it looks exactly
similar
so this was uh essentially a copy paste
of the
um of this object over here
and similarly if you look at a few finer
details like
uh this ship you will notice that
there is no wake compared to bishop
where you can see that there's wake
so things of uh you know
small details and also like um
essentially that some an
image will obviously not violate the
laws of physics you can probably
understand
that an image is fake and then there are
other things which you can look at for
example
the temperature the weather data if the
time if the
image showcases a particular timestamp
you can probably even see
like uh the sunlight direction where it
is coming from
and so the shadows will actually show
that
and this is a demonstration of how a
copy of an object and we copy paste it
elsewhere and
uh over here you can see that this
hovercraft we can copy and i can paste
it here
and that essentially showcases a lot of
military strength
kind of to mislead other countries
but this is something which can't be
done
right now because this is kind of if you
see
for example the first video of which i
showed you of
of tom cruise uh it's really difficult
to detect defect
so uh but there's a problems and so we
have a solution as well
and the first is that we can use an
image-based model
and so you have this uh input video
you're going to extract that into frames
and then you're going to uh get
like extract the face from that uh frame
so
uh if you look at the entire image it
might not convey a lot of information
and it's may not be that useful
so if it's a defect video typically the
part which is manipulated is the face
itself so
it's better to just look at the phase
and then you can
use face alignment techniques to
essentially
rotate that face uh somewhat so that uh
it's always straight it just helps
the classifier and then you're going to
pass that to a 2d cnn
a cnn is a neural network architecture
specifically suited for
image tasks so you can use an
architecture like resnet or an efficient
net
and then you can finally make a
prediction
and this uh so you will get a prediction
for every frame in that video
and then you can use some kind of
scoring strategy to
get your final prediction of the entire
video
then you can also use a video based
model so
in the previous approach we used
an image based so that we were using two
dc engines
you can also use a 3d cnn and what does
that what
that does is essentially looks at both
aspects which is special and temporal
so it kind of processes the entire video
at
one go and you can since it's also
looking at the temporal aspect so if
there are
artifact you know disappearing and
appearing in the next frame or something
like that
small changes can also be caught by the
classifier
now a defect detection challenge was
hosted on
kaggle so it was hosted by
facebook amazon and
microsoft and uh and one trend was that
the
like all the top performing solutions uh
they
didn't use digital forensic methods like
sensor noise uh fingerprints
which can extract a lot of uh
information from
uh image creation like you know when you
create an image
it kind of has a lot of information but
if you let's say copy paste and
an object which like we saw uh it will
add its own
uh fingerprint noise and that can be
easily picked up
so for example uh we have a real face
on the top and a fake face at the bottom
and if you do
a noise level analysis uh since this uh
fake photo has been like kind of like
essentially a face map
the part of the face which was swapped
and blended you can see
uh the the noise level analysis will
kind of reveal that
and uh and it's the same with error
level
analysis as well so this can be kind of
uh used to detect uh defects as well
so there's this paper called face x-ray
for more uh general phase 4g detection
and the good thing is that you don't
need uh
any kind of uh defect data set to begin
with
so all it needs is real face uh real
face
faces and it kind of generates
fake faces on its own by essentially
blending those faces we talked about
landmarks before and the way it creates
its own
sort of fake faces is by it picks up a
random image
it will uh calculate its landmarks and
it will
look for uh in in the data set we'll
look for its
closest uh pair of image which also says
similar landmarks and it just kind of
blends those images
and so what happens is that you you
created this
fake image and you also created the
blending mask so the blending mask is
where
these two sort of faces got blended so
that you have the background face and
the foreground face
and wherever the part of the image the
both the
images were kind of blended you get that
final mask and so
so you have a pair of masks
for every fake image that you create and
uh
and essentially if you have a real image
you do not have a face mask
if it's a fake image you have a face
mask so
essentially what you can do is image
segmentation so
an image segmentation is essentially uh
splitting an entire frame
into and drawing like a sort of a
an overlay over each and uh every object
which is different from each other
so for example over here you can see a
human with a type of overlay and a
different overlay on vehicles for
example
so since now we have uh uh
created our own data set so keep in mind
that our own data set
a fake a fake image will have this sort
of a blending mask
and a real phase won't show any blending
mask
so essentially you're going to try to
predict where that image
has been blended and you can do this
using
a kind of a unit like architecture
where you have down sampling and an up
sampling network
so the final prediction is a fake image
if
the architecture detects that there is a
blending mask and if it's not a blending
mask
if there is no blending mask it
essentially means that
the image is real
then you can also for example look at uh
video metadata to essentially uh
detect if a video is fake and
for this approach you do not need uh to
look at the pixel level
what you instead going to look at is
stream descriptors
so every video sort of has uh some
metadata
associated with it and even if some of
the metadata tags are missing
you can use something like ff pro to
extract
all uh like metadata possible from the
video
so and once you gather all these
metadata and
it contains things like what codec it is
using time base
fps whatever codec it is using audio
protect
and so on and so forth and whenever
a video is kind of manipulated some of
these stream descriptors change
and it changes in a way which is not you
know kind of
correlated or constant with the real
videos
so by essentially looking at uh the
stream descriptors
you can detect if a video has been
manipulated or not
and another strategy is to look at
semantic integrity
and that one what that means is you're
going to look at particular features in
an image
so if
you're given an image you can calculate
a lot of stuff from by looking at its
metadata
things like gps and time so you know
uh the weather data uh corresponding to
a particular time in a particular gps
location
and you can gather all the weather data
from it like sun
angles temperature humidity and weather
information
and you can also train a neural network
uh to detect
all these things on its own so just by
looking at an image
you want to train a neural network to
estimate uh
all these uh values so
and then you can compare can you sort of
compare
or the sun angle calculated by the
neural network and the sun
angle which uh which the weather data
shows
and uh if there is a difference between
these two
you can say that this is a fake if it is
kind of the same it essentially tells
that
it's a real image and the last thing
which you can do is
sort of an audio analysis so
there is something called a spectrogram
a spectrogram can be
generated from raw audio by
taking its uh fourier transform or
wavelet transform
things of that nature so you have this
raw audio signal
and uh you can calculate its uh
spectrogram and then
kind of train a neural network to detect
like fake and real videos just by
looking at the spectrogram
so the spectrogram is uh kind of
has very i sort of put
you know peculiar features when uh audio
is
generated by ai and by looking at these
kind of features
you can predict uh whether uh
the audio is fake or not
uh so our deep fake detection pipeline
at sentinel
particular has been you know kind of
model after cyber security standard of
defense in depth
and so we have multiple kind of neural
networks looking at various features
uh starting from metadata to semantics
uh integrity and like uh
just uh image and video based methods
and also look at the audio
now defects aren't all bad they have
their own
good use cases as well which was kind of
well they were invented in the first
place
for example you can bring old memories
to life
over here you can use an app called deep
nostalgia
which has been woke up late so it kind
of
uh animates a a picture
you can take like any old photograph you
have and it will sort of
uh you know animate animated which is
kind of
really nice
also like for example if you want to
hide your digital identity
uh you can do that so there was this
documentary shot
of anonymous survivors of health of the
lgbtq plus
uh community and the this community was
in chechnya
and they did not want to reveal their
identities so some volunteers
appeared and they kind of some people
volunteered to
allow their face to be swapped uh on
these uh
faces of the survivors to anonymize them
you also have a lot of uh interesting
use cases in hollywood for example
so uh there was you can see the
screenshot uh
of the film uh the irishman and over
here robert de niro and al pacino's uh
you know faces were kind of de-eased and
typically this requires
uh a lot of first of all a lot of money
and a very big va vfx studio
and this is kind of a bottleneck if
an indie producer or a small scale
production house wants to
do these kind of uh you know apply these
kind of vfx technologies
but with defects this barrier is kind of
lowered a lot
so there goes uh to democratizing
hollywood
and of course you can improve your
virtual interactions
by uh animating your digital avatar
so i generated this avatar from a
website called ready player me
and then you can kind of animate this
face
into the way you want to talk so it kind
of improves your
virtual interactions uh in the age of
digitization and with that
i would like to wrap up my talk and
thank you for coming to my pi data talk
i'll be taking questions
[Applause]
okay uh
we have one question uh from demeters
uh does the fs can generate
ships too no it's just for the face
right
yeah it's only for faces so like defect
we have a question from valley but i
think it's
missing some context
how about audio was using what data can
you elaborate on that
uh so if you have like audio clippings
of
real and like fake audio like you can
like train
a neural network on it uh like the first
step you need to do is to
essentially uh get a spectrogram of that
audio clip
and then just look at this spectrogram
so that be done by a neural network
great
any other questions oh yes
uh okay a question from stephen uh
will the detection method you talked
about distinguish
between deep fake and more com more
cosmetic
or artistic changes
uh sorry i'm not sure to understand the
question
uh so some of these if the data is kind
of you know labeled as a defect
it will only like detect if there's a
defect so you have like cosmetic changes
it won't be picked up but if you train a
classifier to particularly look at
uh you know cosmetic changes then it
will be picked up
we have a question from alti is there a
large-scale demand for detecting deep
fakes
or other than other than cases such as
google
facebook all the social media uh
yeah so apart from you know big
companies uh
there is also like governments and
security agencies
which need it so for example darpa which
is the r d bing
of the united states of america they
have
been they have a lot of funding and they
are trying to detect
defects and essentially any kind of wiki
manipulation
wait
uh that's another question from
fushira uh how do you know which portion
of a picture frame to check for deepfake
um so the procedure is like you pass in
the entire video
so and then you can like split that
video into frames
and every frame is going to be checked
and now if your question is to delete
which portions of a particular frame
that you want to look at
uh so so typically in a defect we uh
video the part which is manipulated is
the face
so you can just crop out the face and
then you can
you know like like look at like
particular features
so and the way you can extract faces
from a frame
is by sorry by
using some sort of a face detector so
something like mtcnn
would work
great um
i can see that there's a question if uh
defects are getting harder to detect
and uh yes it is uh it's always kind of
like a cat and mouse game
where the detectors uh beat the
generators and the generators then again
beat the detectors so we have to improve
uh detection methods
and uh as you notice like we have like
there are a lot of ways
how you can detect so and if you
kind of utilize multiple methods uh it
kind of
gets very hard for the generators to
essentially
make sure that all of these kind of
features are taken into account when
they're generating